I mean we'll get married
if and when we ever feel like it you
know we have a really good thing going
now and I don't think we want to mess
with that Vanderpump Rules couple Tom
Sandoval and Ariana Maddox Calling it
Quits after cheating allegations surface
Tom reportedly hooking up with co-star
Raquel Levesque an eyewitness sharing
this video with E.T Tom and Raquel
together on Valentine's Day
did Uzi schwarzenberg help make out this
after she sparked hookup drama with the
show's other Tom Tom Schwartz this year
I kind of did a deep dive and really
opened myself up and experienced new
things being single
um and just kind of like living it up to
the fullest E.T has confirmed the
longtime loves are done and cameras are
back up and filming the aftermath of
their split which will be edited into
season 10 of the reality hit currently
airing on Bravo this summer has been so
[__] awful to me soon after the news
broke Friday the pump rules cast started
weighing in on social media with
messages of support pouring in for
Ariana who deactivated her accounts amid
the ordeal I have a lot to say
you [__] with Ariana you're
with a gang of folk
we're coming for you I am T Mariana all
day every day
that's what's up if you're in Orange
County okay and you're planning on
seeing Tom Sandoval on the most extra
strike don't forget to bring the
tomatoes and the Cabbage okay you want
to get a good aim and you want to
squeeze the tomato a little bit so it's
just a little juicy before you throw it
a source close to the cast also telling
E.T the group feels like Tom has been
going through some sort of mid-life
crises the girls are rallying around
Ariana but no in time she'll be okay
ET has reached out to Reps for Tom
Ariana and Raquel for comment
[Music]
thank you